il faut changer de politique et le
gouvernement italien avec sa prise de
position avec le blocage des ports je
crois je le dis a fait oeuvre utile pour
qu'on change de politique donc vous nous
dites qu'un ministre de l'extrême droite
en italie a fait bouger positivement les
choses l'extrême droite c'est vous qui
parlez maintenant sinon je crois que
vous le classer ou alors c'est pas comme
ça qu'ils se qu'il se classe en tout cas
la ligue du nord elles dépassent très
largement quand même les racines que
vous évoquez c'est un gouvernement qui
est élu il ya le mouvement 5 étoiles qui
est à rattacher on aurait fallu au
fascisme avait c'est un gouvernement de
coalition coalition
donc bien sûr je sais qu'il est de mode
dans le politiquement correct de
dénoncer ces formes de gouvernement de
populisme mais en tout cas vous savez à
mépriser le peuple un moment le choeur
le peuple se révolte et il est en colère
moi je ne méprise pas le peuple et le
peuple
il a un bon sens le bon sens de dire
aujourd'hui les politiques migratoires
et nous conduisent elles ont connu un
échec majeur il y a des morts en
méditerranée
et ça personne ne peut le dire vous
pouvez pas le nier et si monsieur
salvini fait reculer les morts en
méditerranée
eh bien il aura fait oeuvre utile mais